R
man we meet it
last we have been
oppressed we are forced to ride the back
of a bus so a white passenger could
see innocent black men are in
prison how many more have to be slain
for America to say enough is
enough we're in this together how can I
help
you we will lead people to real equality
in this
country to fight against oppression by
any means
necessary what you're doing is
just never question
that brothers and
sisters are you
[Applause]
ready I believe you're going to do great
things we must be a little
daring
we can change the course of
history be careful evil looms over
everything this is our reality
now
who do you think this is going to hurt
more you or me I imagine it's unlikely
to hate either one of us well then let's
keep them guessing Ain man to
[Music]
Li